so Carol you also I believe were working
with Robert or are involved with him
when there when he was working on his
Academy Awards book as a he was working
on the book on the Academy Awards oh yes
with his first Academy Award book I mean
we didn't have a nickel between us and
several of us who loved him 80 from
Crescent Heights in little apartment and
we would go over there every night as we
all got off work from doing whatever we
were doing and and we would sit there
and hold the pictures up like this he
said but Ginger Rogers hire nothing
that's as high as she's gonna go and we
did that we did you know helped him do
that book and I noticed I think Diane
you were probably there he acknowledges
the first edition after that we were
dropped like a hot potato I never
brought that up to him Oh
and years later again it's his humor see
I thought he was I thought he was just a
fabulous person but he was funny and
when he was ill at the end Tom and I
used to call him every week there a
certain time we would talk to him and so
on this particular day he had trouble
talking and he said let's talk about the
good old days so we went to when we had
no money and this and I said Oh Bob
remember when you used to take me to
auditions I had no car he had a car and
it was a be up Chevy so we would go to
auditions here he was driving I only
knew one number and it was called red
hot mama and so I sang it at every
audition and he would sit
there listen to it now he was very ill
we're sitting in I was here Oh remember
that Club and I became emotional which
he wasn't crazy about no no no yeah Oh
Bob Bob tell me something wonderful
agency want me to do something
meaningful just tell me anything he said
Carol I do have one thing I said yes yes
about me you say don't ever sing we're
done it hot mama again
[Applause]